figaro live il est 16h52 nous sommes en
direct et dans quelques minutes nous
pourrons enfin répondre à cette question
qui sera le nouveau premier ministre
jean castex est en ce moment même à
l'elysée pour déposer sa démission nous
attendons désormais un nom on a des
pistes une en particulier alors que je
coupe le son parce que voyez vous nous
sommes en direct voilà comme ça ça va
mieux je suis dit les drops grand
reporter au figaro au figaro magazine
figaro magazine c'est vrai merci d'être
avec moi françois-xavier bourmaud que
grand reporter aussi au service
politique alors on a des pistes on a une
qui se précise on va en parler ça y est
jean castex est en train de démissionner
il est à l'elysée comment ça se passe
dans ces cas là habituellement je dit
habituellement c'est le secrétaire
général de l'elysée alexis colère en
l'occurrence puisqu'il semble un mec
qu'il reste à son poste au moins
jusqu'aux législatives qui va sur le
perron pour annoncer le changement de
premier ministre 'l'annonce d'abord que
premier ministre jean castex en
l'occurrence a remis sa démission au
président de la république qui l'a
accepté et il donne le nom du nouveau de
la nouvelle ap 30 oui parce que c'est ça
à l'information ce devrait être une
première ministre on verra on en
discutera comment on prononcera le nom
de ce premier ministre françois gally ce
sera sûrement pas comme ça cette fois on
nous annoncera un communiqué puis plutôt
passation un peu plus tard dans la
soirée oui c'est un exercice qui aiment
pas beaucoup alexis kohler de parler au
micro sur le perron de l'elysée ça il
avait un peu bafouillé la première fois
pour les annonces de gouvernement et il
y a un petit phénomène au sein de
l'elysée c'est que alexis colère c'est
l'homme fort au kotel macron c'est son
bras droit et quand il parle sur le
perron de l'elysée tout l'elysée se met
aux fenêtres pour guetter un peu et
surveiller s'il va pas bafouiller s'il
est dans un moment de faiblesse d'hier
la seule fois au sein de l'elysée où il
pratique un exercice qui ne maîtrisent
pas vrai qu'on le voie moi je me suis
jamais alexis colère et les seuls
moments où on entend parler lui on
entend que sans le savoir c'est à ce
moment là un exercice qui n'aiment pas
trop est ce que cette fois il a dit non
très peu pour moi normalement pour
solenniser l'événement
doiret s'il doit devrait respecter le
rituel républicain qui consiste à venir
sur le perron a annoncé le nom du
premier ministre c'est un quinquennat
qui est reconduit dans la continuité de
celui des macros pour un deuxième mandat
doux qui peut se permettre de faire une
entorse mais émet macron avait promis
de la nouveauté faire parler alexis
kohler ça pourrait en faire partie alors
sachez que jean castex vient quitté
l'élysée donc le communiqué pour
annoncer la démission de jean castex
officielle est théoriquement le nom du
nouveau premier devrait trouver d'un
instant à l'autre alors comment ça c'est
passé tout le week-end parce qu'on a
l'impression que ça dure on me disait ce
matin jean castex doit démissionner
finalement c'est que cet après midi
pourquoi ça prend autant de temps la
judith depuis trois semaines bientôt et
puis depuis de même le début du week end
plusieurs hypothèses
la première étant que
emmanuel macron attendait de voir quelle
physionomie politique
allait prendre ce lendemain de
présidentielle il ne pouvait pas prévoir
que la finaliste du second tour
marine le pen allait s'effacer à ce
point elle a pris je pense ou le
contrôle de françois xavier darcos ou
est presque audition on a beaucoup vu
jean luc mélenchon alors que oui jean
luc mélenchon a occupé la scène et puis
a sorti
ce coup médiatique que beaucoup trop
formidable que moi je trouve
invraisemblable de dire puisque je n'ai
pas gagné la présidentielle élisez moi
premier ministre mais apparemment ça a
pris ça à parler en tout cas à des gens
de gauche
qui ont été déçus soit qu'ils avaient
voté mélenchon qui ne cédera pas réussi
à se qualifier encore une fois soit pire
encore elle est votée pour anne hidalgo
qui a fait de moi un vieux huile 74%
alors on va attendre dans l'est dans les
moments qui viennent vous réagissez
évidemment vous posez vos questions sur
le figaro.fr sur tout sur youtube on va
être d'habitude on a des images de la
cour de l'elysée là on n'aura pas ça
est-ce qu'on veut justement essayer de
rendre les choses un peu plus secrètes
un peu plus sans en faire étalage voilà
on annonce un premier ministre et puis
il ya une continuité comme ça sans
forcément faire des caisses en fait
aimer le maquereau là il est dans une
nouvelle une nouvelle séquence après
l'élection présidentielle ait eu autant
de décantation s'y rendre prendre en
compte les le message qu'avait été
envoyé par les français à l'élection
présidentielle analyser les résultats
voir un peu ce qui ce qui se passait
dans le pays et en tirer les conclusions
il ya eu un deuxième temps qui était un
temps de reconstruction notamment
politiques avec la construction de cette
nouvelle majorité c'était l'accord entre
elle et m le modem et le parti des verts
philippe horizons pour structurer le vin
c'est ça c'est un mensonge pur pour
structurer la majorité présidentielle
qui est qui qui allait partir en
campagne pour les élections législatives
elles en arrivent dans un troisième
temps qui est celui de la nomination du
premier ministre et donc il faut
s'organiser quand même un peu
l'événement parce que c'est si on écoute
nn macron c'est une nouvelle période qui
va s'ouvrir donc il s'agit de deux
semaines et trois semaines et calculer
on a l'impression qui malheureusement
ils ne trouvent pas le nom c'est très
étonnant d'habitude en certains
présidents en tout cas candidats
annoncés oui je sais m'en souviens de
françois hollande ce cachet assez peu
que jean marc ayrault serait son son
premier ministre là il fait campagne
sans avoir aucune idée de qui sera son
premier ministre alors en réalité le nom
d'elisabeth bornes ça fait très
longtemps qu'il est dans l'atmosphère et
sans doute même peut-être un peu trop
longtemps puisqu'on parle d'elizabeth
banks celles qui pourraient qui pourrait
être nommé en remplacement de jean
castex ça fait ça fait plus d'un mois
mais avouez plus de plus d'un mois qu'il
est dans l'atmosphère un mois c'est
extrêmement long ça donne le temps aux
adversaires d'elisabeth bornes de faire
campagne contre elle ça donne le temps à
d'autres éventuels candidats de faire
campagne pour eux et puis bah et aux uns
et aux autres de ceux de ce dégommer le
dernier épisode en date c'est vendredi
soir quand le nom de catherine vautrin
au leader alors ça ça m'intéresse
explique est mort le canon entrent dans
l'atmosphère souvent c'est pour pour
l'empêcher
par bienveillance voilà c'est parce que
le nom de catherine vautrin ne sort pas
de nulle part enfin il y avait une idée
d' emmanuel macron et s'il fuites dans
la presse c'est que quelqu'un a envie de
dévitaliser vraisemblablement le
scénario qui est dans l'atmosphère et
qui ne plaît pas une partie de la
majorité en l'occurrence la gauche de la
macro ni qui s'est déchaînée tout week
end en face surtout samedi d'ailleurs
pour pour dynamiter torpiller les le
scénario d'une dune catherine vautrin a
maintenu que vous voyez à l'image des
catherine vautrin qui n'est pas
forcément très connu du grand public qui
a été ministre par le par le passé mais
qui n'est pas forcément très connus
alors le nom de favoriser des dites moi
pas très connue vous avez raison mais
c'est pas forcément à défaut étant donné
le profil parce que ce qu'on a su assez
rapidement c'est qu'elle profite ni à
chercher emmanuel macron fait le coup
avec edouard philippe et jean castex des
personnalités vocoder edouard philippe
on ne savait pas quand je parle de
profil je parle pas simplement de la
notoriété je parle aussi des rapports
qu'il peut avoir avec le l'occupant de
matignon là on sait qu'en gros l'idéal
pour lui ce serait jean castex en femme
mais on l'a su très vite je suis très
vite c'est à dire quelqu'un qui ne
nourrit pas d'ambition personnelle qui
est un règlement loyal dévoués qui
applique la politique décidée par le
président de la république bref un
collaborateur
fiable et hyper fiable pour emmanuel
macron vous l'avez compris deux noms qui
ressortent il ya un suspense un mine de
rien catherine vautrin tendance plutôt à
droite elisabeth bornes tendance plutôt
à gauche et cette question de arthur sur
twitch king emmanuel macron se voit
obligé de nommer un premier ministre
femme pour quelles raisons c'est vrai on
s'attend à un nom de femme et rien
d'autre
il avait déjà essayé en 2010 est de
nommer un premier ministre femme
mais bon il n'avait pas le pas le banc
de touche
c'est une sorte de défi personnel qu'il
ce sens mais aussi une façon de marquer
son engagement féministe parce que c'est
quelque chose qui lui a été beaucoup
reproché dans le pendant le quinquennat
d'en avoir fait pas tant que ça sur
l'égalité hommes femmes
malgré des déclarations qui était plutôt
tonitruante pendant la campagne
et c'est aussi une façon d'essayer
d'enclencher une nouvelle ère le seul
qui a nommé le premier ministre femme
avant lui c'était françois mitterrand
avec edith cresson s'est jamais arrivé
depuis sur toute l'histoire la cinquième
banque voilà il ya une femme premier
ministre sur 24 premier ministre c'est à
dire c'est vraiment une singularité
statistiques donc c'est une façon de
marquer aussi la nouveauté de cette de
ce second quinquennat est aussi que
précisément parce qu'il veut quelqu'un
qui ne serait pas d'exister
politiquement et surtout d'exister à ses
dépens
ça veut dire une personnalité assez
effacé ou en tout cas très discipliné il
fallait un truc en plus donc le truc en
plus c'est de nommer une femme
autre élément aucun nom ne s'impose par
exemple d'une personnalité qui serait
extrêmement populaire dans le pays quand
françois mitterrand nomme michel rocard
en 1988 et tout le monde s'y attend
d'ailleurs il ya quasiment annoncé avant
sa réélection
c'est pourquoi c'est à cause d'un
immense popularité long terme occupation
du terrain
h il pas du tout les mêmes visions
culture l'autre est
persuadé que appelé rocard à matignon
serait la meilleure façon de le tuer est
la meilleure façon que l'opinion qu'il
adorait voit son véritable caractère à
savoir second france a mis 40 quelqu'un
de velléitaire et ne peu courageux donc
une femme qui n'a pas d'ambition ce
sackboys et s'approche des territoires
aussi c'est ce qu'on entend
régulièrement est ce que c'est possible
ça est ce qu'on a le profil parfait ça
n'existe pas non dans le profil idéal
n'existe pas on voit bien dans tous les
noms qui ont circulé ces derniers temps
qu'il y avait toujours un moment quelque
chose qui rentrait pas dans les cases
mais bon et même accro au président de
la république sont quelques uns des des
gens de pragmatique et un moment il faut
bien nommer quelqu'un donc
peut-être par défaut
il va y voilà enfin semblables ont
plutôt le scénario elisabeth bourguinat
qui tient la route alors qu'ils qui est
pas quelqu un des territoires comptera
mois catherine vautrin mais qui en
revanche coche la case
environnementale puisque oui alors on
sait attention parce qu'il devient cette
promesse des menus et le mal qu'il a
fait à marseille et je vous en prie vous
avez non parce que si vous voulez
dépenser ici avant tout le monde quelle
prime nice je vous accorde le droit de
recevoir des messages françois xavier
oui et une demande d'avoir un premier
ministre qui serait en charge de
l'écologie avec deux ministres délégués
sous sa personne lancé ça pour bien
montrer
toute l'importance qu'il attache aux
problématiques
de développement durable de préservation
de l'environnement c'est un terrain sur
lequel
il a cru marquer des points en oman
nicolas hulot personnalité la plus
populaire du moment on sait comment ça
finit oui d'abord moi ici on dirait que
ça représente et puis après avec des
utilisations deux heures seulement
de l'intéressé dix ans je me suis trompé
je pense est possible de mener une
politique
compatible à la fois avec mes
convictions environnementales
et avec
les programmes des manuels macron c'est
une erreur il n'y a pas de politique
environnementale compatible avec la
gamme acronis était une des grandes
heures du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
le mandat de nicolas hulot à
l'environnement parce que ça ça à
camoufler toute une part de l'action
environnementale
demel macron c'est lui par exemple qui
renonce à notre dame des landes qui
renonce au projet minier de la montagne
d'or en guyane qui fait fermer le prat
qui fait annuler le projet de centre
commercial europa city enfin il ya tout
un tas de gestes environnementaux qui
ont été totalement gommée effacée par le
départ de nicolas hulot et
depuis il a changé de braquet cyr qui
cherchent une personnalité qui incarne
l'écologie mais une personnalité mais
qui va plutôt réussir à convaincre qu'il
faut développer le nucléaire pour pour
assurer la transition écologique enfin
quelque chose de plus pragmatique sur
l'environnement 17h04 nous sommes en
direct pendant jeudi nous sommes en
direct en attend évidemment le nom du
nouveau de la nouvelle premier ministre
alors comment on va l'appeler justement
ça ça marche ça m'intéresse madame le
premier ministre madame la première
ministre madame la premier ministre
le pirée parce qu'elle saurait me dire
comment on appelait comment être créés
sont se faisait appeler mais ce que vous
preniez me madam le premier ministre
alors est ce que c'est la personne ne
m'ait qui décidera comment ça se passe
généralement
vous croisez une colle mais c'est
intéressant savoir comment va nommer
pour nous la question va se poser très
vite de savoir comment les cris dans
votre intérieur dans nos papiers nason
course qu'on va se réunir au journal
pour pour en décider à partir du moment
où
premier ce mot féminin pourquoi pas m la
première ministre services de rap est un
peu à l'écriture à la lecture et
peut-être les oreilles aussi parce qu'on
n'est pas habitué effectivement ce
système là jamais jamais entendu mais
après tout pourquoi pas essayer de
féminiser le poste dont judith jeu
de type comment se fera appeler ce 1er
mai cette première ministre dans les
dents les jours à
maquereau et les autres arrêtent avec
celles et ceux mais comme je n'ai aucune
chance d'être
on a eu beaucoup de beaucoup d'attentes
est ce que c'est un poste qui fait
encore rêver premier ministre est ce que
on a vendu ça ne se refuse pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça se refuse de premier
ministre plusieurs personnes ont fait
savoir qu'elles avaient été approchés et
qu'elle avait refusé
alors notamment à gauche
par ont
des entretiens préalables enfin des
prises de contacts effectivement il ya
deux personnes qui ont fait savoir
qu'elles avaient refusé valérie b d'agde
la présidente de du groupe immobilier
nexity et
rabaud
valérie rabault ces deux années
précédentes des voix la [ __ ] et ps à
l'assemblée nationale alors qu'on fait
savoir que bon c'est apparemment ça n'a
pas été au delà des prises de contact
mais il ya des prises de contacts qui
sont suffisamment explicites pour que le
message passe sans qu'il soit formulée
c'est le match mais on peut ne pas avoir
été proposée directement mais peut avoir
très bien fait comprendre de quoi il
s'agissait donc être dans l'entretien
quand vous allez voir alexis colère à
l'elysée bon c'est pas pour beurrer la
tartine comme on dit le nom de catherine
votre argent et qu'on y revienne parce
qu'il est sorti tout le week-end
plusieurs de nos confrères disent et
c'est bon ce sera elle qu'est ce qu'il
s'est passé pour que ce nom aujourd'hui
ne soit pas forcément l'unique favori on
parle d'elle ou d'élisabeth board on
attend la décision d'un instant à
l'autre
l'hypothèse a été crédibiliser vendredi
soir
par des articles de presse ou des
informations de presse expliquant que ça
y est c'est fait c'est elle dans la
foulée réaction immédiate de la gauche
delà de la macro ni c'est pas possible
ça peut pas être elle est donc il ya eu
charge conseillé d' emmanuel macron pour
lui demander de renoncer à ce projet et
puis d'aller vers plus plutôt quelqu'un
d'autre la la la campagne anti vautrin a
été très forte samedi beaucoup de
déclarations au sein de la deûle à ma
chronique je vous coupe un instant
freinée mais parce que ça vient de
tomber le premier français jean castex
annonce avoir remis sa démission à
emmanuel macron ça c'est officiel
donc la tâche du nouveau premier
ministre
est dans l'instant à l'autre je vous
laisse continuer sur catherine vautrin
donc oui et tout cet cette campagne de
conseillers de daimiel macron de
demandes de l'ama chronique qui ont
expliqué que vu les déclarations qu'elle
avait faites ses prises de position sur
le mariage contre le mariage pour tous
sur le fatou tout un tas de choses donc
auquel venait de la droite il y avait
déjà eu deux premiers ministres de
droite pendant le premier quinquennat
qu'il était temps de passer à gauche
enfin bref ya une campagne qui à
dévitaliser le
l'idée qu'il n'a pas sorti du champ mais
en tout cas qu'il l'a dévitalisées
meymac on a pris conscience
des problèmes qui risquent de rencontrer
en nommant catherine votre à matignon
surtout avant une campagne électorale
déterminante pour lui puisqu'il s'agit
d'obtenir une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale donc voilà que le nom est
sorti et puis le le fait que le nom
sorte un produit son effet ses dires il
a été dévitalisées
majorité et surtout de réduire autant
que possible le score de la coalition le
nuxe de jean-luc mélenchon sachant que
le nul sans question est
constituée certes des lecteurs
mélenchonistes qui adhèrent à cette
vision du monde a sa vision de la france
à son projet et puis de d'électeurs de
gauche orphelins de leur propre candidat
ou ans dans le camp
s'est dépeuplé mais qui ne partagent pas
forcément les conceptions de la france a
soumises donc emmanuel macron dans son
raisonnement que se dire qu'en nommant
une personnalité de gauche
soit venant du parti socialiste
soit centristes faisant plutôt à gauche
il y en a été le radical de la gauche
elisabeth demande si ces mecs qui venait
être
au moment où il a été question notamment
à l'initiative de bruno le maire
ministre l'économie est un peu d'edouard
philippe de remettre sur le métier la
réforme des retraites qui
en a fait un casus belli et les
nouvelles bandes ça montre la tendance
d'elisa le tournoi et c'est pas rien le
sujet des retraites a évidemment mieux
dans le quinquennat qui vient de
s'achever ni dans celui qui commandait
alors vous soulever une question si elle
venait à être nommé ce qui est
l'hypothèse la plus probable à l'heure
où on se parle il faut voir la porte s
est très fort mais sur cette image là
pour les là pour appliquer la politique
d' emmanuel macron donc qui est des
concessions telles qu'elles ont été
formulées par emmanuel macron lui-même
dans l'entre-deux tours c'est à dire bon
de laisser à 64 pourquoi pas fin de
l'année des ajustements mais le
oui moi j'y crois pas une seconde mais
en tout cas sous la pression il a déjà
fort et ça l'a fait toute la question
pour emmanuel macron c'est savoir si
leur les nuques oula du ps dont la
nouvelle union populaire éclate avant ou
après les législatives parce que quand
on regarde dans le dans le détail il ya
absolument rien qui colle dans cet
attelage mais absolument rien sur
l'autre grâce on est d'accord sur le
burqini personne n'est d'accord sur les
investitures personne n'est d'accord et
plus on cherche plus on fouille plus on
regarde dans le dans les programmes la
seule chose qui rassemble le la nuque du
ps c'est
le rejet des mails maquereau en tout cas
la volonté de créer un groupe d'obtenir
des sièges à l'assemblée nationale pour
créer une force d'opposition alternative
cette attache cet attelage là ne peut
pas tenir sur la durée pardon je vous
couvre le relais mais ce qu il en a
vraiment peur de ces législatives
emmanuel macron à ce qu'il nomme un
premier ministre vraiment en vue des
législatives
on a l'impression qu'il prend beaucoup
de place et que c'est lui qui va la
mener cette campagne des législatives
n'en oui c'est lui enfin le premier est
que le chef de la majorité ce sera pas
elisabeth bornes ce sera l emmanuel
macron dans tous les scrutins
importants du quinquennat passé c'est
lui qui est monté en première ligne
illégaux aux élections européennes quand
il s'agissait de deux d'affronter marine
le pen qui avait fait de ces élections
un référendum anti macron mais macron de
descendre dans l'arène plus personne
n'entend parler d'elisabeth loi d'un
talus l'oiseau avons japon prennent
aujourd'hui les ateliers le jeu on est à
partir du moment où elle mêle macron il
va donc le chef de la majorité ces
modèles macron faut pas se leurrer est
ce qu'elle peut mener les abbés de bord
d'une campagne des législatives on peut
parler de sa personnalité en ce projet
est allé c'est la favorite est-ce
qu'elle a le charisme la prestance parce
qu'on sait que c'est important en
politique pour pour et bien
être premier ministre j'ai très bas puis
dire qu'elle a une grande marge de
progression
vous avez elisabeth von ah je
travaillais un peu à secrets de cuisine
quand elles participent à une grande
émission politique les journalistes
politiques se lamente parce que ça va
être très très dur de retirer une phrase
voire même une idée parfois un élément
elle est vraiment
extrêmement lisse et ce n'est pas
qu'elle n'a pas de conviction elle est
extrêmement en retenue dans le lit père
contrôle de son expression publique fait
vraiment attention à tous et chacun sait
qu on ne s'exprime qu'à son détriment on
ne sort de l'ambiguïté qu'à son
détriment donc l aile et par an mais
pour vous dire quelque chose serra est
d'ailleurs oui dans le quinquennat placé
pas souvenir d'une déclaration marquant
d'une prise de position forte de
7 à huis clos ça n'est pas sortie elle
ne la maladie publique
17h13 nous sommes en direct et nous
continuons à attendre nous imaginions
que cette nomination du nouveau premier
ministre pouvait être effective dans les
dans les minutes qui venait on a une
certitude jean castex n'est plus premier
ministre il a présenté sa démission ça y
est c'est fait il a quitté l'elysée il
est retourné à matignon la passation
devrait avoir lieu ce soir aux alentours
de 19 heures emmanuel macron est-ce
qu'il ne prend pas trop de place j'ai
une question vous connaissez très bien
les arcanes de la politique ces
négociations est ce que ça peut
refroidir des potentiels premier
ministre l'importance que prend emmanuel
macron d'avoir un rôle finalement comme
l'avait jean castex d'aller le jeudi 10
raconté 2
vous voyez ne pas avoir cette hauteur
d'homme d'état évidemment quand on est à
un peu mythique affirmé et ambitieux au
bon sens du terme je pense par exemple à
une carole delga qui est la présidente
socialiste de la région occitanie qui
est en fait à la tête de la rébellion
anti muller champ qui va soutenir des
candidats qui ne participeront pas à la
nuque et qui s'en distingue même et voir
qui s'y opposeront dans certaines
circonscriptions quand on est une femme
comme elle allait nouer d'une forte
personnalité de fortes convictions d'un
projet qu'elle défend on n'a aucun
intérêt à se mettre sous la coupe des
manuels macron ce qu'ils cherchent
vraiment un super directeur de cabinet
c'est plus le rôle de premier ministre
politique qui emmène la majorité qui et
qui parfois dans l'histoire la 5e s'est
imposé au président de la république
pour paraître au caire tout à l'heure là
c'est vraiment le choix du président et
c'est une des caractéristiques de de
ceux du quinquennat passé et donc
peut-être du quinquennat à venir c'est
que tout procède et relève d' emmanuel
macron et à commencer par la nomination
du premier ministre sachez que elisabeth
bornes serait en train d'arriver à
l'elysée et ça se confirme ça se
confirme on and on attend 'l'annonce
évidemment vous reste encore un petit
peu avec moi je sais que vous avez des
papiers à écrire pour le journal jeu
c'est réglé je sais mais les gens
attendent ils veulent savoir qui sera
premier ministre dont les coulisses
comment ça se passe habituellement
est-ce que c'est emmanuel macron qui
appelle directement est ce qu on sait
comment ça se fait comment faisait ses
prédécesseurs comment lui agi pour
trouver un premier ministre pour trouver
des ministres alors ça dépend ça dépend
de la personnalité un premier ministre
évidemment à un moment c'est le
président de la république qui décroche
son téléphone on n'a jamais vu quelqu'un
s'installer à matignon après avoir après
en avoir discuté avec
l'assistant du président voilà assistant
du bout alors ça part très très mal ça
prouve qu'ils rêvent très très mal non
évidemment c'est le coup de fil final le
coup de fil décisif il est donné par
emmanuel macron savez vous comment ça se
passe quand c'est xavier est ce que vous
avez eu des gens qui vous disent blanc
m'a appelé vous imagine qu'il ya des
personnalités qui ont déjà dû recevoir
des propositions comme ça tout comme a
dit judith
allez on prend par ivoire on ne s'avance
pas trop je voudrais revenir sur la
question du genre et du sexe de ce
premier ministre de cette première
ministre il ne peut plus reculer il ne
pouvait plus reculer cette fois qui
s'est mis dans une telle seringue en
un ensemble d'abord lui pas cette fois
ci mais la fois précédente que son
ambition était de nommer une femme et
cette fois ci en laissant dire que c'est
effectivement toujours son objectif qui
créerait de la déception du simple fait
de ne pas en nommer une
et ça lui aurait reproché
donc il a ils sont gays moi je considère
que c'est un gadget politique
je suis absolument contre le fait de
nommer quelqu'un à cause de son sexe
c'est je trouve que c'est les pires
service à rendre au féminisme mais c'est
démagogique donc la démagogie ça
fonctionne et puis ça souligne encore
plus le l'aspect fait du prince de du
président de la république qui fut une
sorte de caprice
je vais une femme à matignon il ya ce et
qu'on avait qu'on avait vu à deux
reprises au précédent quinquennat avec
edouard philippe et jean castex qui
était 2-2 personnalités qui n'était pas
du tout dans le scope habituel des d'un
casting pour pour matignon la elizabeth
banks est exactement la même chose voire
les noms qui ont qui en tournée
uniquement des femmes il y avait sept
cette volonté effectivement deux marqué
par la nomination par pas inédite mais
quand même un peu discrétion ça remonte
à longtemps mais pas le nominer
l'émission d'une femme un bâtiment qu'on
entrait dans une nouvelle ère dans un
nouveau mac rond dans macron 2 mai dans
macron 2 ya macron toujours macron qui
se veut progressiste mais qui est
souvent entouré d'hommes on lui a fait
le reproche encore pour les législatives
avec cette image de richard ferrand de
stanislas green ni de françois bayrou et
d'edouard philippe avec son secrétaire
général alexis colère qui est un homme
avec ses premiers ministres qui ont été
deux fois des hommes il était obligé
alors bon c'est vrai qu'il est entouré
beaucoup d'hommes aux fonctions
importantes
quand on regarde un petit peu quand même
rob owen fonctions physiques l'on tende
à l'elysée quand même assez féminisé il
y a fat il ya de bayser 4 générale
adjointe d'autres on a parlé un moment
pour matinée aussi il y avait six bêtes
ndiaye qui était directeur de la
communication directe de la presse il
ya quand même tout un personnel féminin
à l'elysée c'est pas c'est pas investir
de revenir
une première manif sans importance car
macron perdra les législatives disait
wendel qui me dit ça sur youtube est ce
que on pourrait avoir une première
ministre qui ne reste qu'un mois parce
que les résultats sont très bons tout à
fait alors perdre les législatives
moi j'ai beau tourner et retourner
ça me paraît peu vraisemblable mais pas
impossible après tout peu vraisemblable
qu'elle le président de la république
avec la construction que rappelait
françois xavier c'est à dire en
agrégeant toutes les composantes du
maquereau nisme ensemble selon le nom
extrêmement politique et signifiant
qu'ils ont trouvé après des heures de
brainstorming
réussissent à ne pas avoir la majorité
absolue dans l'assemblée qui va être élu
le 19 juin donc nous souhaitons ça il
aura la question c'est à quel hauteur
seront les autres
à quelle hauteur sera le bloc youtube ce
hack à quelle hauteur sera aussi le
rassemblement national puisse quand même
le pô le principal pôle de position va
être un des deux il n'y a logiquement
logique arithmétique aucune raison que
marine le pen arrive devant le nuxe
puisque elle a reçu les commissions
l'alliance avec le parti d'eric zemmour
qui a pas d'alliance non plus avec les
républicains et quant aux républicains
eux mêmes et au parti socialiste sont
pas du tout du tout en état d'espérer
quoi que ce soit c'est parti républicain
je m'avance un peu peut-être mais arrive
à obtenir 30 sièges à ben ali ils sont
très très content non en réalité qu'un
seul scénario dans lequel elisabeth
bornes parce qu'un mois à matignon
cécile un port du lac rond il avait deux
bornes si elle est nommée par les mines
et ce n'est pas officiel si vous nous
rejoignez en attente bâton des
guillemets ça c'est celui où le mma
qu'on perd les élections législatives
renaissance n'a pas la majorité c'est un
cas improbable mais c'est le seul
scénario devrait tenir compte de la même
journée car la majorité mais voilà même
en tête à voir le prince fidèle c'est
pas le c'est pas le plus problème si il
a une majorité
il peut ensuite rééquilibré son
gouvernement en faisant entrer des
secrétariat d'état des secrétaires
d'états différents postes pour pour
renforcer les pôles ministériels parce
que là là on parle de la nomination à
matignon n'est pas encore entré dans la
la deuxième étape du remaniement que
celle des nominations de ministres et
parez vous parce qu'on refait la même
chose dans trois jours à joal annonce
peut-être même plus tard parce que c'est
ça risque d'être compliqué peut-être des
grands pôles au début avec des postes
ouverts justement pour tenir compte des
enseignements des législatives mais il
met aujourd'hui par hakan peu
vraisemblable que le premier ministre
que va nommer emmanuel macron dans peu
de temps oui un enfant tu as l'autre ne
ne franchissent pas le mois de juin je
lui dit j'ai une question parce que je
lis beaucoup de monde sur le figaro.fr
un peu déçu d'entendre le nom
d'elisabeth borne est ce qu'il peut y
avoir un effet déceptif pour employé les
mots d' emmanuel macron avec ce
vocabulaire a nommé
isabelle borne ramon qu'on connaît
depuis 20 ans principe d'une surprise
c'est qu'on n'a pas la connaître
c'est si c'est elisabeth bornes
effectivement la surprise aura été
largement éventé plus de mystère donc
c'est une déception en soit maintenant
du mac on doit faire avec ce qu'il a
les surprises total ça avait été edouard
philippe qui était
à la fois en termes de profil et à la
faire en termes de trajectoire politique
à double très bon coup
je crois pas qu'il soit en étal mais bon
j'ai peut-être démenti dans quelques
minutes
prudence prudence mais c'est vrai vous
avez raison le fait qu on s'attend tous
à ce que ce soit elisabeth baume
amoindri l'impact positif chorale à la
nomination d'une femme à matignon est ce
que jean castex parce qu'on doit bien en
parler et c'est lui qui quitte le poste
ce set ce format qui est inédit avec un
président qui est réélu et qu' eva mine
de rien reconduire l'une de ses
ministres dans son gouvernement au poste
suprême jean castex peut-être l'avais
dit je vous l'avais dit c'est vrai ne
vendons pas la peau de l'ours avant de
l'avoir tuée
aurait dû retourner on répète on
réexplique elisabeth borne est la
favorite mais elle n'est toujours pas
nommé est ce que jean castex peut
favoriser cette transition est ce que ça
peut être plus simple on le sait lui il
a ce sens de l'état ce devoir mais il
envie de partir un si j'ai bien compris
dans un peu marre qu'on le premier
ministre par on va le voir ce soir après
la cérémonie de passation de pouvoir il
quitte la cour de l'elysée et puis basta
il s'en va il y a
il ya un impératif a laissé le nouveau
premier ministre s'installer prendre
prendre prendre ses marques ensuite un
coup de fil un conseil enfin le il ya
souvent des anciens premiers ministres
qui reviennent à matignon
déjeuner avec le
leurs successeurs mais c'est à dire que
ce soir le nouveau premier ministre
hariri ils se retrouvent sur le perron
dans la cour de matignon mais il ne
s'isole pas tous les deux pour discuter
comme celle ci faisait un petit moment
dans le bureau où le voilà ce sera la
même voilà pour la passation de pouvoirs
soit mais la passation c'est important
on al'exemple sort d'une passation de
pouvoir ce qui c'est extrêmement mal
passé c'est le départ de gérard collomb
place beauvau du ministère de
l'intérieur jeu se rappelle que faute de
de mon profil cet exemple d'ailleurs
edouard filet premier ministre avait
assuré assumer pendant
plus d'un mois je crois de mémoire une
période de cet ordre là et le ministère
de l'intérieur et ses fonctions de
premier ministre et ç'avait été terrible
entre les deux hommes puisque jarre que
l'on avait profité de l'occasion pour
sur le perron de l'escalier de secours
de la place beau
expliquer qu'il est c'est une situation
explosive où les gens qui dans les
quartiers vivent côte-à-côte pourrait
syrienne été faite hier par le ministre
de l'intérieur qui allait le remplacer
se mettre à vivre face à face et il
avait cité les islamistes et les
trafiquants je vous livre un tout petit
peu je sais que vous avez des papilles à
écrire et après je vous lâche 1
malheureusement si on n'a pas de
nouvelles des manuels macro l'elysée
mais ça devrait tomber d'un instant à
l'autre oui mais je vais faire une
semaine c'est vrai elles sont vous
pouvez essayer de se projeter un tout
petit peu sur les ministères qui vont
être distribués finalement est-ce que
certains ministres pourraient rester au
vu du contexte je pense au contexte
sanitaire en mine de rien est ce qu'on
est vraiment sorti de cette pandémie je
pense au contexte de guerre en ukraine
est ce que certains ministres pourraient
être amenés à rester à florence parly la
ministre de la défense elle part déjà
fait savoir qu'elles qu'elles qu'elles
faisaient ses cartons donc il y aura du
changement
et pour le reste
on est vraiment dans le black out total
à la emmanuel macron circuits lents il
est coincé en fait dans une exigence
contradictoires qui est celle d'incarner
le changement dans la continuité
donc la belle la continuité ça pourrait
vouloir dire laisser bruno le maire à
bercy pour
assurer la stabilité économique du pays
voilà c'est ce jeune chômeur on voudrait
d'accord il y aura une certaine logique
à ce que bruno le maire face disant ah
merci et c'est inquiétant
pour le montre aux politiques est trop
ambitieux
alors dans l'entourage de l'hiver on dit
quand même que
ça va il a fait le tour de la question à
la santé se voit bien exercer des
responsabilités plus régaliennes et puis
surtout emmanuel macron après avoir
promis de manière un petit peu anticipé
le retour des jours heureux voudrait
bien tourner cette page là et je propres
ne serait ce que pour marquer que l'aco
vide est derrière nous il y aura un
changement a dit seigneur une place à la
santé c'est toujours la nécessité du
changement et de la continuité et donc
il faut contrebalancer les ministres qui
resteront par des personnalités de
nouvelles qui marqueront et ça c'est un
équilibre qui est extrêmement subtile et
complexe à construire d'autant plus
qu'ils ça suppose aussi de tenir compte
de l'enseignement des législatives donc
de faire entrer d'autres me
personnalités après c'est un autre jeu
vous soumettre celui de jean yves le
drian lui ministre des affaires
étrangères depuis dix ans un
gouvernement sous françois hollande sous
emmanuel macron et vouloir partir des
discours voulant oui il dit et même
françois hollande qui est son ami
annonce qu'il va partir mais alors pour
le coup s'il y en a un qui pourrait
rester parce que le contexte en ukraine
l'imposent c'est lui non
c'est compliqué d'être ministre des
affaires étrangères quand vous avez
emmanuel macron qui essayent de rayonner
tout seul sur la scène internationale
il a fait il fait un gros travail de
coulisses jean yves le drian n'est pas
très pas très visible en revanche le
travail politique sans doute pas été à
la hauteur il était là pour structurer
la gauche de la macro ni et on voit il
ya territoire de progrès cette espèce de
machins et qui n'arrivent pas existé qui
autant les ministres de droite ont
réussi à structurer quelque chose dans
le premier quinquennat ce dieu qui avait
du poids politique les ministres de
droite ou autant les ministres de gauche
on papa pas réussi à
l'adhésion à créer l'équivalent de leur
côté un tweet je vous coupe un instant
emmanuel macron c'était il ya une minute
merci à jean castex et à son
gouvernement et à toute son équipe
durant près de deux ans il a agi avec
passion et engagement au service de la
france soyons fiers du travail accompli
et des résultats obtenus ensemble avec
une photo des deux hommes y le prochain
premier ministre aura une tâche lourde
un jean castex il l'a convaincu le
président il avait le rôle parfait l'
équilibre parfait entre
techniciens sur qui on peut compter sans
prendre trop de place
oui enfin c'est en tout cas il n'a
jamais
gêné et makro
par ailleurs son humilité
son attitude simple lui ont servi aussi
de paratonnerre mais même ali ben moi je
suis frappé de voir que alors qu'ils
auraient bien des choses à dire sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui l'avis général est que
finalement a été très bien gérée on
oublie vite oui il s'installer
tranquillement j'ai souvenir d'une
interview qu'on avait fait au tout début
de jean castex où ça partait absolument
dans tous les sens on avait mis
énormément de temps à écrire le texte
parce qu'ils sautaient d'une idée à
l'autre et au premier abord on s'était
dit ça va être un peu fouillis ce ce
truc là et puis finalement il s'est
hissé installés çà c'est cadré le côté
bonhomme est ressorti assez ferme aussi
apparemment qui est un volet qui est pas
pas tellement ressorti aux yeux du grand
public mais une fois les portes de
matignon refermé il pouvait piquer des
colères auto à se montrer extrêmement
ferme en ayant l'habileté de faire en
sorte que ça se sache pas pour que les
personnes qui faisaient l'objet de ses
colères soit pas du milieu donc il a
réussi à mettre en place une forme de de
travail inspira un peu de respect auprès
de ses équipes qui quand on regarde la
composition du gouvernement sont pas des
bleus a parlé des ministres de droite
quand ils ont vu arriver jean castex
élus de maire de prades oui bon brûler
certains voilà qu'à certains pedigree ça
sera plus frotter puis finalement tout
ça sert voilà et ça s'est bien passé
donc effectivement c'est une perte sans
doute pour mails macro mais il fallait
tourner la page pour incarner le toit le
tournant du nouveau quinquennat j'ai une
dernière question et après je vous
libère puisque malheureusement nous
n'avons toujours pas l'annnonce de ce
premier ministre même si on vous le
rappelle élisabeth borne est en ce
moment à l'elysée combien de temps après
pour composer un gouvernement si
la nouvelle premier ministre est nommé
ce soir combien de temps après
quelle est la procédure ce que dit à la
haute autorité
c'est ainsi c'est un machin pour faire
un gouvernement complet le texte c'est
le premier ministre composent son
gouvernement et le propose au président
de la république c'est le premier
ministre qui officiellement propose son
gouvernement la réalité c'est que ces
mails macron et le premier ministre qui
le maquereau
et tout ça se fait alors c'est moins
vrai avec les macs ont peut-être qu'on
pourrait revenir après mais il ya
toujours des subtilités d' équilibre
territorial
iliad est donc l'équilibré hommes femmes
la parité homme-femme à respecter il ya
telle ou telle région qu'il faut qu'il
faut représenter il ya les minorités
qu'elles soient présentes au
gouvernement il ya le handicap il ya
tout un tas de critères gérant danse de
gauche et de droite
qui les politiques
l'avantagent des mails macron par
rapport à toutes ces contraintes la lui
ne pouvant pas se représenter il est
tenu par justement aucune contrainte
politique il peut nommer qui il veut de
toute façon dans cinq ans il est plus là
il n'a pas à se ménager des dés
la sympathie de barons locaux
comme il a pu en avoir un
les décors impressionnants
je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord on
n'arrête pas de dire que la l'identité
du locataire de matignon sera un signal
politique pourquoi parce qu'il a promis
que ce quinquennat qui s'ouvre ce
deuxième calcul un second quinquennat
qui s'ouvre sera celui que n'a pas été
le produit celui des réformes
mais ma croix a été élu après avoir lu
et écrit un livre programme s'appelait
révolution ya pas eu de révolution du
pavot qui les crises
qui ne sont pas de son fait je parle de
la coved et de la guerre en ukraine pour
justifier la maigreur de son bilan
réformateur ça a marché une fois ça
marchera pas deux fois et donc pourrait
former où il aura besoin d'un certain
calme dans le pays est en tout cas que
les oppositions ne soit pas vent debout
et en capacité de mobiliser les foules
contre ces projets une révolution c'est
un tour complet sur soi même certains
points
nous avons normalement le nom du premier
ministre ce soir est potentiellement
alors je suis allé chercher un dernière
fois jean castex avait été nommé le
vendredi 3 juillet et alexis colère
était revenue annoncé le gouvernement le
lundi matin le site donc ça a été rapide
cet effet dans le week-end et puis
edouard philippe lui avait été nommé le
8 mai il avait annoncé son gouvernement
le disent alors que c'était prévu le 9
mai il y avait eu un peu de temps parce
que la haute autorité de la transparence
de la vie publique était passé par là
vous savez que chaque ministrable à voit
son cv son parcours son passé son
patrimoine et son patrimoine passé en
revue pour qu'il n'y ait pas de problème
pas de compte en suisse par exemple on
peut parler de ça voilà merci beaucoup
j'ai dit grand reporter au figaro
magazine françois xavier bourmaud grand
reporter au service politique bon nous
sommes désolés nous n'avons pas pu vous
annoncer le nom du premier ministre le
nom de la premier ministre on vous
rappelle que jean castex a démissionné
c'est officiel qu emmanuel macron a
accepté cette démission et l'a remercié
dans un tweet qui est d'isabelle borne
est en ce moment même à l'elysée elle
est l'immense favorite pour devenir
premier ministre
et puis d'ici une heure une heure et
demie passation de pouvoirs à matignon
entre jean castex et son successeur sa
successeure on suit évidemment ça sur
figaro live on se retrouve dans aller
une heure une heure et demie à tout à
leur merci de nous avoir suivis